vamos a comprobar que lo que dije en el
vídeo pasado pues sea real por lo tanto
vamos a tomar una sucesión aritmética
cualquiera la que ustedes se les ocurra
o mejor aún la más general y vamos a ver
si podemos encontrar su serie entonces
yo tengo aquí mi primer término que es
am ya a lo que hacíamos para encontrar
el segundo término era sumarle de esa es
la definición de una sucesión aritmética
y por lo tanto si yo quiero encontrar el
tercer término lo que tengo que hacer es
sumarle a través de entonces me queda a
más 2 dm y así etcétera etcétera hasta
llegar al término n pero como
encontramos el término n
bueno este es el primer término este es
el segundo término y date cuenta de algo
le agregamos una d
este es el tercer término y date cuenta
de algo llevamos aquí dos veces de para
el cuarto término vamos a agregarle tres
veces de iu para llegar al término n lo
que hay que hacer es sumarle n menos 1
veces d es decir siempre le agregamos d
pero en esta ocasión para cualquier
término le agregamos n menos 1 vez estén
para el término 32 para el término 21
para el término 10
etcétera muy bien esta es mi sucesión
aritmética más general que puede haber
ahora vamos a buscar su serie y como
encontramos su serie pues para esto voy
a utilizar el color amarillo que no
encuentro por aquí es que muchas veces
cambiar de color es lo más difícil de
este vídeo aquí está mi color amarillo
entonces tengo las series aritméticas lo
que estamos buscando es la serie o la
suma de los primeros n términos de esta
sucesión aritmética y como lo
encontramos pues vamos a ir sumando
tengo el término 1 más el término 2 más
el término 3 que es a más 2 d más el
término etcétera etcétera y hasta el
último término que es a más en el -1 por
d y voy a hacer la misma lógica el mismo
truco que utilicé en el vídeo pasado en
el qwest acabamos la serie de los
primeros en en números naturales voy a
utilizar lo mismo y lo que hacía era
escribir otra vez esta suma pero al
revés por lo tanto voy a empezar con el
último término el cual es a más n menos
1 por d entonces me queda a más n 1 por
d y después a esto le tengo que agregar
un término pero era del final al
principio es decir a más n 2 x de este
es mi penúltimo término y después el
antepenúltimo término es decir a más n 3
por d fíjate que lo que estoy haciendo
es reducir en 1 lo que está dentro del
paréntesis más etcétera etcétera
etcétera hasta el primer término el cual
es el término inicial es decir a muy
bien y yo escribí a estas dos sumas
porque que creen voy a sumar las de
nuevo lo mismo que hicimos en el vídeo
pasado entonces la serie de los primeros
en términos más la serie de los primeros
en los términos pues es dos veces la
serie de los primeros n términos
ahora me voy a fijar en los primeros dos
suman dos de estas series voy a hacer
otra vez la operación pero vertical a
más a más en el -1 por de me queda dos
veces a por en el -1 por de muy bien
hasta aquí en el problema vamos a ver
mis segundos sumando me queda más de más
y más en m2 por de y esto es lo mismo
que 2a y después aquí tengo d
en dos por tres y esto es lo mismo que n
uno por de date cuenta de esto fíjate
vamos a hacerlo aquí arriba tengo de más
n 2 x de d es lo mismo que uno de m
entonces si yo factor hizo la de que me
va a quedar me queda n 2 más 1 y todo
esto por de tiene menos dos más uno es
lo mismo que en menos uno que multiplica
a d es decir lo que les contaba en el
-1% entonces me queda dos más en el -1
por de n menos uno por día y ahora me
voy a fijar en mi tercer sumando tengo a
más dos de más en m3 por de a massa son
2 am y 2 de más n 3 por d pues tengo 2
de ella aquí tengo en m3 de que me queda
pues me va a quedar en el -1 por de otra
vez en el -1 por de m más etcétera
etcétera etcétera pero date cuenta que
cada uno de estos etcétera es lo mismo
ya encontramos el patrón dos más en el
-1% y en los últimos dos suman dos
verticales tengo dos
+ n 1 por d es decir que ya vimos aquí
claramente el patrón que se cumple y
cuántas veces sumamos esto cuántos dos a
más n 1 x de tenemos en mi afirmación es
que son n de estos sumandos pues si te
das cuenta los tenemos n veces fíjate
tenemos 1 2 3
etcétera etcétera etcétera y este era mi
término n por lo tanto tenemos en a
veces esta cantidad es decir que 2 veces
la serie de los primeros en de términos
es igual a n veces todo esto que
encontramos 2 am más n 1 x de esta
expresión que yo tenía aquí 2 a por n 1
por d y bueno ahora qué es lo que va a
pasar si yo paso dividiendo el 2 o dicho
de otra manera
/ ambos lados de la ecuación entre 2
pues me quedan n que va a multiplicar a
dos más en menos uno por d a todo esto y
todo esto hay que dividirlo entre dos
porque estaba pasando el 2 dividiendo y
aquí ya tengo una expresión para
encontrar la suma de los primeros n
términos de cualquier sucesión
médica que se me ocurra sin embargo la
vez pasada no llegamos a esta expresión
llegamos a una expresión que tal vez es
más cómoda si yo no tengo el último
término es decir tiene el problema no me
pone en último término pues puedo yo
aplicar esta fórmula que tengo aquí y
entonces no necesito el último término
tengo a n tengo a 2 am y tengo la razón
pero si yo quisiera encontrar la suma
como la encontramos la vez pasada como
el promedio del último término más el
término final como lo sacó recuerdan la
vez pasada tenía este promedio x n como
llegó de aquí allá son iguales estas dos
expresiones esta y ésta serán lo mismo
porque llegamos a una fórmula para
encontrar la serie de los primeros n
términos sin embargo hasta ahorita no he
llegado a a que la expresión que vimos
en el vídeo pasado sea correcta sea
factible y suena bastante lógico porque
lo que estamos escribiendo aquí es tomar
el primer término sumarle el último
término promediar estos dos términos y
después multiplicarlo por n es decir
multiplicar esta cantidad por n
esto y la respuesta es que si lo único
que hay que hacer es maniobrar un poco
la expresión que tenemos aquí arriba
vamos a hacerlo tengo que sn voy a
ponerlo aquí abajo sn es igual y lo
único que voy a hacer es abrir un poco
esta expresión que tengo aquí tengo 2 am
pero 2 a lo puedo escribir como a más a
más n 1 por d y todo esto todo esto que
está aquí lo podemos dividir entre 2 y
que creen aquí ya se nota más lo que les
decía porque a quién tenemos aquí a es
igual al término inicial justo así
empezamos este vídeo recuerdan está aquí
arriba y en el término n es decir mi
último término es igual a más n
1 x 10 lo pueden ver aquí arriba así es
cómo definimos el término n por lo tanto
la suma de estos dos dividido entre 2 es
el promedio del primer término más el
último término es decir justo lo que
veíamos en el vídeo pasado y está genial
porque ya ven no les mentían pues no
solamente encontramos una expresión para
la serie sino que encontramos dos
expresiones para
los primeros en términos de cualquier
sucesión aritmética